welcome to this video against a V and
see 1964 okay going for Queens gambit
yeah I wanted to try out the route goes
in myself this is some plate so often
nowadays I'm not sure how well the white
players are prepared queen bee three is
actually one of the sharpest moves yeah
I wonder if he's just like inventing
stuff here are really playing out some
sort of preparation okay he takes I
guess I really have no idea how it is
played I think the queen bee three there
was a game Kramnik against Nigel short
some years ago where we're short really
got killed yeah any any other word would
be probably too too friendly okay I'm
trying to go for d for him
GRT for is a threat Oh interesting
didn't think about that move but I can't
take here though right it's nothing
wrong with that I oh I see so what
produces idea I can go here and then the
night c7 okay if I go Bishop to b6 you
might have Queen a three interesting I
can start with before however it's May
that's probably better and let's let's
let's gain this temple first and then
move the move the bishop
Queen a4 I guess huh where am I going
cream pretty 6s till 97 but should be
six Queen a3 still would have 94 wow
that's quite complicated if you just if
he allows castles now I'm I'm in
fantastic shape because he has a hard
time to even develop his stuff and
pieces are on coordinated but i wonder
if Bishop before or queen a3s as a
problem for 96 check I think I have yeah
I have this move that was what I had
planned and now this even it's even
possible that maybe Queen D Phi versus
in there attacking the the night down on
b5 or just a or just a six by the way a
six that would actually win the night it
has no wait nowhere to go Oh quite quite
nice maybe I'm I'm really okay here
q looks looks noisome a 6 e 6 and widest
what is really don't but just what
doesn't really have a square for the
night it's really a problem yes i have
night c5 amongst others but i can also
take one Bishop f5 Bishop f5 is this too
much what about 95 though let's let's
check that one Queen Queen III may be
still I can take it to what's also not
bad at all quindi 5 yeah I wonder what
he what he plays if I play something
like 25 maybe early wasn't sure and
there are so many good looking moves
this keeps the pressure on
mmhmm yeah maybe just back to a 30 or
something something like that okay let's
get all of this a 592 I cannot believe
maybe maybe he can do that I ok if I can
also just take take with the night of a
like okay but let's look at 92 first 92a
be 69 to be 30 go somewhere that's a
disaster and then a be a be 6 next one
night c5 depends a bit what is doing
man city yes this he always hears 97
here that's a temple on the Queen really
that's working that you enjoy your
joking right didn't pay attention to
that move it off so okay not much I can
do now where exactly that still hangs
what is this I'm a pawn up and I'm a
poner okay don't want to trade I want to
win stuff so not taking be to try to
keep the the pressure on Maddie for not
be force that i dno or just before is
also quite strong it's not quite clear
where he goes and it's also nice
just pushing forward white resign yeah
plus the time time situation Jay I
probably didn't play it play it best but
it looked quite good i think i think
they play i'm not really sure but i
think the chrome neck game was this
anglong castles or something it was
really brutal what why did but a que
went here ship here yeah i don't i don't
really think that this is good 94 was on
so nerdy for was stronger yeah of course
that stronger it threatens on f2 and
then castles yeah that was much better
actually this is what diseases this is
an IQ p position where I'm I'm better
developed I get castles and and he's
just he lost time with night b5 queen is
not good on b3 and so on that's this was
that that is just better than what I did
doing here I mean the comp gives me an
edge but not not so so great and here
are Queen d5 was this is better okay
night eggs and castles and black wins
yeah okay that's night before and all
kinds of stuff and then still 86 yeah
and the self was really better he can
play oh it can play Queen takes before I
totally I mean I saw the idea but only
later okay i can i can actually do this
and keep an edge but
a white plate back every child really
badly yeah right yeah I can do this and
know this for the poor the night okay
what happened I went to our cam I'm
keeping big advantage or rook f3 I
didn't see that one that was stronger
yeah so I didn't really give anything
away I always kept a very nice position
but I could have one quite quite a bit
quicker okay well thanks for watching